E aí
[Aplausos]
e encontramos um homem com quatro
mulheres numa das zonas rurais de
Moçambique
o e as quatro mulheres cada uma delas
tem a sua parcela de terras
e onde produzem produtos para a
alimentação da família
e o homem tem a sua parcela de terra
onde produz o orgulham
e as quatro mulheres trabalham para além
das suas parcelas de terra na parcela de
terra um homem pelo menos dois dias por
semana
E no fim da campanha as mulheres
providenciam alimentos para a
subsistência da família e o homem vende
o algodão
e quando perguntamos quem traz a renda
na família a resposta foi o homem porque
o homem que vende o algodão é ele que
controla a renda
e de fato é uma sambique certa de
cinquenta por cento de pessoas
envolvidas na produção do algodão são
mulheres mas noventa porcento das
pessoas envolvidas na comercialização
são os homens
nós estamos a falar daquela mulher
o que acordar muito cedo
Oi para o seu local de trabalho que a
maxambomba
e antes de voltar para casa esta mulher
com letra frutos silvestres tira algumas
raízes Qual é essa linha e quando chega
em casa cozinha e cuida da família
e percorre longas distâncias à procura
de água agravado hoje pelos efeitos das
mudanças climáticas essa mulher processa
os alimentos e ainda participa é
atividades comunitárias a sua carga de
trabalho extremamente elevada 12 horas
14:16 horas de trabalho ao dia
E aí esta mulher Rural que nós estamos a
falar o papel da mulher rural no
desenvolvimento da economia com verde o
papel produtivo a mulher
O que é determinado por tarefas que
contribuem para o bem-estar da família o
bem-estar econômico da família e da
sociedade em geral
E é esta mulher que nem sempre essas
tarefas resultam imediatamente é receita
e por exemplo a mulher Rural é a
principal utilizadora da terra e dos
outros recursos naturais
a geradora de renda mas nem sempre é
reconhecido aqui está o dilema da mulher
rural no desenvolvimento da economia um
dilema expressivo um dilema
multidimensional tendo em conta que
cinquenta e dois por cento da população
em Moçambique é constituída por mulher
e as quais 64 por cento nos encontramos
nas zonas rurais
a oitenta por cento da mulher Rural
dedica-se à agricultura de subsistência
a oitenta por cento dos produtos básicos
para o consumo nas zonas rurais são
produzidos pela mulher
os 99 porcento da terra arável
e eu não são BIC é determinado por
pequenas explorações agrícolas
determinado pelo setor familiar
e onde 34 por cento é dominado por
mulheres chefes de família
a 56 por cento de processamento do Caju
é feito por mulheres e 80 a 90 porcento
da apanha da castanha do Caju é feito
por mulheres a mulher transporta o saco
na cabeça até a loja para
comercialização
é mas ela não participa nesse sempre
participa na negociação para comercial
para vender esta produção ela não
participa nem tem voz para determinar a
utilização desta renda
e hoje o homem é que determina o homem é
que diz ide sobre a renda desta produção
aqui está o dilema da mulher rural no
desenvolvimento da economia é um dilema
e torna vulnerável a mulher Rural
vulnerável porque ela não participa da
negociação vulnerável porque ela não
participa em toda a cadeia de valor
e vulnerável Por que não têm voz sobre
produção
ó e vou ler a ver porque não tem não ter
tem esta economia onde tem o patrimônio
que ela mesma produz
e por exemplo 64 por cento de títulos de
Direito de uso e aproveitamento de terra
atribuídos entre 2011/2014 em algumas
áreas floragem Moçambique pertenciam ao
pertence as mulheres
e é muito bonito falar de 64 por cento
onde 47 por cento são títulos
individuais e dezessete por cento são
títulos em regime de particularidade é
bonito ver esses números mais analisado
os 14 que afinal as mulheres Rurais de
ter títulos em parcela de terra onde não
tem infraestrutura a maioria dela porque
existe a percepção de que é uma guerra
Rural não traz renda para a família a
mulher oral não traz economia para
família este o dilema da mulher rural no
desenvolvimento da economia
e este dilema
o Fernando Renato a mangueira
a E agora o que vamos fazer
a causa
oi dinda Action and System
Esse é o sistema de aprendizagem e Ação
gênero
e é uma abordagem participativa é uma
abordagem e parte da própria comunidade
e é uma abordagem que empodera aos
homens e as mulheres
e tem uma abordagem que valoriza o papel
da mulher o papel dos homens é uma
abordagem que desenvolve
as relações de gênero e
com esta abordagem tem alguns princípios
e um dos princípios dos Direitos Humanos
da mulher não se negociam
O que é que o homem é parceiro aliado
para mudança e não é inimigo
e é uma abordagem que começar na
comunidade e uma abordagem e tende a
partir do próprio indivíduo e é baseado
na prisão
e é uma abordagem localmente fácil
desenvolver é um abordagem que mesmo
aquelas 58 por cento de mulheres adultas
nas zonas rurais que não sabem escrever
nem ler também podem desenvolver porque
funciona com símbolos funciona com
diagramas e funciona com mapas
e é uma abordagem e tem diferentes
instrumentos e um dos instrumentos para
esta abordagem é a árvore do gênero com
ver a árvore do equilíbrio de gênero
facilita que homens e mulheres consigo
identificar a contribuição da mulher a
contribuição dos homens
e o que que a mulher economicamente para
família o que que o homem tá já
economicamente para família quando o
patrimônio da mulher qual é o patrimônio
do homem
e depois são as lacunas deste a relação
de gênero Justa e tomará consciência
o individual daqui é preciso mudança é
preciso criar mudanças transformativas e
com base nessas mudanças temos as ações
para caminhar nesta visão que é uma
visão individual uma visão e parte da
própria a pessoa
e assim o papel da mulher rural na
economia não tem movimento da economia
Onde cê para o fortalecimento desta
relação de gênero e esta relação de
poder esta relação de a mulher e o homem
podem criar essa transformação dando
valor a contribuição das mulheres rurais
no desenvolvimento da economia muito
obrigada